the other big issue that they've got
right now is the border and we know you
guys are watching this show so we've
covered it plenty i mean the border is
in effect open right now and thousands
of people are pouring through the border
we're giving them phones we're giving
them benefits we don't know where they
are much of this happened while we were
in this pandemic and they were allowed
to come in without masks while we
wouldn't let our own citizens from
foreign countries come in with masks i
mean just all of the the litany of
nonsense right uh it just never ends and
then of course yesterday there was
actually a truly horrific tragic event
where 51 migrants were coming in in a
van that i think caught fire right uh
what happened
did it catch fire i think it caught fire
but 51 migrants were killed
on their way in because the government
has signaled to people
uh health and homeland security director
becerra and biden and kamala they have
signaled to people oh you can come and
then every now and again they go oh
don't really come
but they basically said come the van was
actually abandoned in the heat and they
they in essence died of heat stroke it
was a semi-truck i mean horrific like
actually just like beyond horrific
whether they should come here or not 51
people are dead like that and their only
reason they're dead is because they
thought they could get in because our
policies are so muddled and they
probably knew people who did get in so
what's happening is as this type of
stuff leaks out even the people
who have backed biden who have backed
all of the progressive policies who have
called trump and the rest of us racist
for wanting a wall or wanting a border
or whatever else even they are now
realizing that they were wrong and here
is guy who is pretty much always wrong
about everything joe scarborough
it's one thing i don't understand
uh
it it's kind of like
when i talk about homelessness there's
nothing progressive
about
having people uh sleeping in 10 degree
weather sleeping on greats that's not
progressive
there's also nothing progressive about
encouraging migrants to risk their lives
going across the desert
to come into the united states illegally
it's just extraordinary though because
it is progressive to do that it is
progressive to say that borders are not
good and that everyone can be here and
we are here for everybody and open for
everybody and by the way we're also the
most evil racist country in the world i
don't know why you want to come here but
okay you can still come here and yes
homelessness is progressive because
everywhere progressive politics are put
into practice
that is where homelessness thrives
that's where you get tent cities that's
where you get the drugs and the rest of
it do i have to go through seattle and
portland and uh san francisco and los
angeles and denver and everywhere else
that's where it's happening so you can
say it's not progressive and i get that
you guys you know you pretend that we
all are there's something wrong with all
of us but i get it you guys have like a
bug in your brain and that bug is like
you cannot make the connection between
all the stupid things that you say and
do and votes that you make and then what
that actually does to people on the
ground so you're saying it's not
progressive but actually it's the most
progressive thing having people come to
a country uh that there is not enough uh
resources for them or have uh high tax
positions so that more and more
homelessness comes into a city these are
the progressive policies of today it's
just that you sound like a nice guy as
you're ruining everybody's lives we've
got more from the televised mental
institution known as msnbc here's willie
geist realizing finally that biden and
the democrats have a problem there was a
special election just a couple of weeks
ago down along a border a district a
place where a republican hadn't won in a
very long time and a republican took
that took that district so there
we've talked about this with progressive
pollsters by the way who say this idea
that
latino voters in america are all in and
they're they have this open mind and
they'll go with democrats wherever they
go on immigration is just wrong it's
just it's just folly and it's not true
and it's patronizing in many ways to
make those assumptions so yeah democrats
will have to reassess because some of
them may not want to use the word crisis
but it's exactly what it is down along
the border when you have customs and
border patrol having
seven thousand eight thousand encounters
and apprehensions a day on the border
that is a crisis
so there's a couple interesting things
there one of them is that the republican
that he's referring to that he refuses
to say her name you know her name it's
myra flores she won in texas's 34th
district as a republican it had been
democrat controlled for 100 years you
may remember that elon musk supported
her he said it was the first time he had
ever voted for a republican it is a
border city it is a place where people
are getting the first hand the first
order effects of this crazy immigration
policy when when the biden
administration refuses to protect our
border which is one of the few things
that the federal government is actually
supposed to do
but they won't say her name and and
that's not nothing because think about
the way the entire mainstream media
pushes aoc down our throat pushes ilhan
omar down our throat and the rest of the
squad we know their names because
they're good young pretty or something
progressive politicians so we should all
know them but here you have a young
woman who is a mother who is latina
who is an extraordinary human being she
wins in in texas right
getting rid of 100 years of democrat
rule and we're not even going to say her
name we're not even going to say her
name